FRED CHUNG: Hi, my name is
Fred with Android Developer
Relations team.
We're going to talk about
improving Android Studio
performance on
memory-constrained computers.
Android Studio comes with
many features developers
expect from a modern IDE.
For example, lint checks
help identify errors
as you are typing source
code in the editor.
These developer
productivity features
mean increased
resource requirements
on the host operating system.
Practically, developers
working on complex multi-module
production projects usually
have 8 gigabytes of RAM or more.
However, if you're working
on a simple project
on a memory-constrained computer
with, say, 4 gigabytes of RAM
or less, we're going to go
through several things you
could do to make the development
experience a bit smoother.
There isn't a definite
answer on the minimum specs
needed to run Android
Studio because there are so
many factors.
An obvious first step is close
any unnecessary applications
on the operating system.
Sorry for those users that keep
20 web browser tabs opened.
For those that have
antivirus software running
on the computer, note that
build files generated by the IDE
may trigger real-time
virus scanning.
This competes for
system resources.
If possible, go to your
virus scanner configuration
and exclude project
build output directories.
Android Studio has a
default maximum Java heap
size of 1.2 gigabytes.
If your computer has low RAM,
you should correspondingly
reduce the default heap size to
something like 512 megabytes.
You can set the
desired values using
the xmx key in the
studio.vmoption configuration
file by following
these instructions.
Note that reducing
this value means
shrinking the amount of
resources for features
within Android Studio.
For example, performance of the
Layout Editor may be affected.
Now let's talk about Gradle,
one of the core components
in Android Studio.
Update to the latest versions
of Gradle and Android
plugin for Gradle to ensure
the latest performance
optimizations are
available to your project.
For example, in 3.0, we've
improved incremental packaging
with AAPT2.
The snippets here shows specific
configurations for the Android
Studio 3.0 beta version.
Your specific
installed version may
need a different set of values.
Next, I'm going to talk
about several techniques that
have to do with
degrading support
and leaving only the
bare minimum running.
Note that some of
these techniques
could provide performance gain
at the expense of code quality,
so you really should
use with caution.
Android Studio provides
a power save mode.
When turned on, it
will disable a number
of background operations that
perform lint checks, code
completions, and so on.
There'll be a point
in time when you
want to execute any disabled
operations manually.
Take lint checks, for example.
You can manually run them
through the command line
as shown here.
Some of you may be using
the Android Emulator.
On average, it consumes
2 gigabytes of RAM.
If possible, use an
actual Android device.
This will help reduce resource
load on your computer.
Alternatively, if you
must use an emulator,
consider emulated
RAM, which will also
decrease virtual memory
consumption on your computer.
This configuration can be
found under Advanced Settings
in Virtual Device Configuration.
Gradle offline mode is a feature
for bandwidth-limited users
to disable downloading
of build dependencies.
As a side effect, this
could help improve
performance on low RAM
machines, since this also
reduces the amount of
background processing.
Android Studio offers
an optimization
to compile multiple
modules in parallel.
On low RAM machines,
this feature
will likely have a negative
impact on performance.
You can disable it in the
Compiler Settings dialog.
I hope this video gives
you some ideas on how
to fine-tune Android Studio
in your low RAM environments
to make the development
experience smoother.
To learn more, check out
the Android Developer site.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]